well the family of the 56-year-old
bicyclist who was killed during an
attack sunday morning is speaking out
for the first time
kristen drummond sits down with michelle
weisman's husband
and her friends who still can't believe
she's gone
and it's a story you'll only see on 8
news now
it's been pretty much a complete shock
comprehending a sudden loss something i
could not even
imagine or dream up if i even
took the hardest effort i possibly could
loni weissman reflects on the life of
his wife michelle
or as family and friends call her
shelley she was a ray of sunshine
that light dimming sunday morning when
the 56 year old was killed while riding
her bicycle on hollywood boulevard in
the east valley
police say a minivan passenger leaning
out the window intentionally pushed her
what happened was a flat out horrendous
and unnecessary tragedy
that was 100 percent avoidable weissman
says charlie started cycling during the
pandemic
her typical route included this stretch
of hollywood boulevard she would go out
and want to ride from here
out to the wetlands park loop and go out
there and ride the bike trail a new
hobby among her many interests according
to
friends she like to go to the gym and
work out you know but her and i you know
we would go to concerts and
when we were younger oh my god we were
we were
we'd love to go dancing shelly was born
and raised in las vegas and graduated
from las vegas high school
friends describe her in three words
compassionate
kind caring
she's always thinking about others
always the legacy those closest say
she leaves behind kristin drummond 8
news now
shelley was the hotel director for the
cannery hotel and casino in a statement
boyd gaming says we are deeply saddened
by the tragic
and senseless loss of our team member
shelly she was well known
and well liked by the entire cannery
team and we will miss her
our thoughts and prayers are with her
family and friends during this very
difficult time